hey youtubers it's Charlie this week on
arrow we found out that the man under
the hood totally doesn't matter we got
the most amazing flash crossover and
probably one of the most important
flashbacks to the island all season long
real quick though if you're finding me
for the first time I do arrow videos
every week with bonus CUNY's be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'm even working on a special countdown
series that I'll explain in a little bit
so let's just go ahead and start with
the title the man under the hood what's
that all about that was actually the big
question when we found out someone's
identity was being revealed I had all
kinds of plot theories which Quentin
went on to answer in his very eloquent
speech well let's talk about that during
my top 5 moments careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet but
here we go number 5
Quentin's man under the hood speech this
is a version of The Dark Knight speech
that Gordon did in that movie which is
fitting because I always kind of thought
there was a strong parallel between
Quentin and the arrow and Gordon and
Batman maybe that means that someday
Quentin's gonna be Commissioner of
Starling city hmm I wonder this was such
a great way to put Laurel into this
really positive mindset as to how she
was gonna deal with learning all of her
secret and I love that Quentin just
flat-out refused to find out I kind of
suspected from the moment Laurel found
out that she was gonna treat this like a
good thing at least once the shock wore
off in that epic hug that she gave
Oliver is just her shedding her last
moment of doubt it was totally great
every time on arrow should be hug time
she's totally gonna become another stuff
member of team arrow at least in the way
Quentin is an unofficial member you know
on the police force and as a quick side
note I totally think we're gonna see an
Oliver Slade hug by the end of the
season like a big bear brother hug they
wouldn't go through the trouble of
creating a mirakuru cure if they were
gonna use it
number 4 Slade is waiting in the arrow
cave this was another one of the best
action sequences all season that seems
to be happening a lot lately it's almost
like a short film you could just cut it
out and post it as a 4 minute trailer oh
wait I kind of think they did that
Stephen Amell even did this really
awesome thing where he posted a funny
breakdown in the episode in this tweet I
can't wait to see him in like a comedic
role Sunday unless you consider Oliver
to be something of a comedian maybe like
a really serious dark comedian in fact
he and Felicity would make one of the
greatest fandom comedic duo's I mean she
already gets most of the funny lines on
the show number 3 Slade is using Roy to
create his mirakuru army even though
they're not a legion of soldiers you
know
if one person on mirakuru is bad then
even a couple of them would be a
nightmare and really on that crazy
tanning booth looking harness was
straight out of a horror movie I just
love how the episode kind of jumped from
noir cop drama to science fiction at
STAR Labs then to horror and Slade's lab
which is really just a credit to the
writing in the set design I'm guessing
that when Roy skipped town Slade
captured him you know he didn't turn
sides if it wasn't clear Roy still has
the mirakuru in him he flips out in the
next episode episode 20 so we know that
he wakes up and gets off that table at
some point just to explain the way I
think the mirakuru works a little bit I
think that the serum acts like a
catalyst for your body's own natural
abilities so once you get injected your
own body just starts producing it in
mass that's why Slade was able to
transfuse Roy into all those of the
people to make them super soldiers and
do the same thing himself with ravager
later in the episode number two there is
a cure for the mirakuru this was one of
the most important Island flashback
scenes ever just because it gave us the
solution to the problem that has been
slayed this season we're gonna make him
human again but there's a big asterisk
whenever Ivo explains how the Cure works
he says that it cures the physiological
effects in the mirakuru but not the
psychological effects it seems like the
only reason Slade has been attacking
Oliver has been because of evil
Tinkerbell shado so if they cure him it
sounds like it won't get her out of
Slade's mind I may have just heard it
wrong but either way he won't be
indestructible anymore so they will be
able to kill him for real meaning that
Oliver's plug enough to make another
choice like he did back on the island
he'll either have to kill Slade or do
something else I keep saying that
Oliver's not a killer this season at
least he's trying not to be but that
doesn't mean that Sara might not try to
kill Slade for him in the same way that
Oliver killed Ivo for her and my number
one moment the amazing flash crossover
with Cisco Ramon and Caitlin snow so
much to talk about here so I'm just
gonna stick to the big stuff and we can
do the rest in the comments first off
the STAR Labs facility they're working
at is like the candy store for
superweapons in case you missed it
whenever they grab that gun Caitlin says
all the tech that was locked in that
area belonged to Arthur Light who was
dr. light in the comic books a super
Looney Toons bad guy Justice League
villain I think we can think Geoff Johns
for including that name dropped he's
written
comic books for a long long time
including the flash and Justice League
and he's actually working on the flash
TV show right now so it totally makes
sense that he would write this episode
they also did a really good job of
teeing up future flash crossovers when
they talked about felicity visiting
Barry he's being kept in STAR Labs
Central City facility that producers
confirmed that he wouldn't wake up to
the first episode of the flash and the
interesting thing is is that in this
episode Cisco and Caitlin talked about
them closing down the Starling city lab
so they're probably getting moved to
Central City and that's how they'll run
into Barry but in case you didn't know
they're actually done with that first
episode of the flash yeah it's totally
done they finished the pilot and Geoff
Johns Andrew Kreisberg and Greg Berlanti
tweeted this picture that they had just
watched it for the first time no word on
when we're gonna get to see it the
audience but hopefully they'll air it
after the arrow finale in five weeks
that's a bit of a long shot though but
here's my one major WTF bonus moment
Slade trans fuses Isabel with mirakuru
to bring her back to life as ravager
Andrew Kreisberg actually just revealed
a whole bunch of details about Isabel's
character she's basically a mash-up of
Isabel rochev from the comic books and
ravager so she basically has Isabel's
backstory you know she was Oliver's
father's lover and just wants revenge on
his family and the TV show is turning
her into ravager the way Slade was
looking at her on the table was kind of
the way a father would look at a
daughter or maybe like Frankenstein will
look at his monster or maybe you know
Bride of Frankenstein so remember how I
said Slade's lab looked like a horror
scene we've all seen the pictures of her
is ravager that leaked online I actually
can't put them in the video but now we
know that she'll be juiced up on
mirakuru which is even cooler Summer
Glau is now essentially playing another
terminator and I'm so happy it's gonna
be so full of Awesome you have no idea
there's also this really cool thing they
revealed about the origins of the
Ravager character on the show they were
gonna do it way differently before they
cast Summer Glau originally they wanted
caity lotz as Sara character to start as
Ravager and then switch back to being
good throughout the season but that was
until Summer Glau was cast because she'd
worked so well as a fighter on
terminator Sarah Connor Chronicles and
all of our other shows they decided to
give the Ravager arc to Isabel but now
it's your turn let me know what was your
favorite moment from the episode was it
the flash crossover was it
Aurel joining the arrow fanclub or was
it that giant ravager teaser at the end
overall the episode was just a solid a
across the board I feel like I'm gonna
be giving straight A's to the rest of
the episodes of this season the show has
done such an amazing job of building
momentum which is incredible considering
how awesome the promise was earlier this
year Stephen Amell had this really nice
rally cry for the next five weeks so I'm
even gonna be doing a special countdown
series that I'll explain in just a
second I really feel like the show's
ability to jump John Roos you know
horror sci-fi noir cop drama is really
what's kept it fresh it's really easy to
get comfortable and then tired with the
format you know like watching your
billionth episode of Law & Order but I'm
really interested to see which genres
they do in the rest of the episodes of
the season and I'm really coming around
on laurels character I know everyone is
still thinking she's gonna become Black
Canary in season 3 but I still think
that's too soon
I think she's just gonna stay in her
current role and start trying to help
team arrow from behind her desk you know
the same way Quentin helps them via the
police force the characters it's really
dangling in the wind right now is Thea
John Barrowman probably won't be back to
the finale
but she's a huge part of the arc next
week so she hasn't completely skipped
town but it's really unclear as to what
her role on the show is right now so I
feel like I've covered all the important
stuff but let me know what your final
thoughts on the episode are and do you
think that Oliver's gonna be able to
cure Slade by the end of the season so
just like normal I'm gonna be posting my
Q&A video tomorrow be sure to subscribe
to get it if you're just finding me for
the first time and to explain that
countdown series each Wednesday morning
I'm just gonna be posting another bonus
video of arrow just to get everyone
super pumped as we get closer to the
finale
so feel free to suggest topics for those
videos in the comments below in the
meantime you can click here to get that
Q&A I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post the video and you can click here to
get last week's episode thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
you